irgendwer nimmt einfach so eine audiatei
her und macht das ein spektogramm und
sieht auf einmal so ein Herobrine
Gesicht jo meine Lieben Villager Freunde
und alle anderen da draußen die Bock auf
Minecraft facts haben herzlich
willkommen zu den Minecraft facts heute
und ich würde sagen ich habe wieder
extrem coole Sachen dabei und ich würde
auf jeden Fall dran bleiben weil dieser
letzte fact bzw einer der letzten ich
weiß nicht der wie vielte das ist das
ist eine extrem creepy Sache wo ich mir
selber so gedacht habe als ob Alter wenn
ich das selber rausgefunden hätte die
schon GZ bekommen aber egal damit ihr
nicht mehr so lange warten müsst würde
ich sagen fangen wir direkt an mit dem
ersten F der wurde mir nämlich
zugesendet von samuro und zwar
war und zwar meint samuro dass man in
Minecraft wenn man einen Enderman in
einem Minecart hat was ich hier habe ich
habe hier ein Minecart und ich habe ein
Enderman Spawner in der Hand und jetzt
Alter fahr doch jetzt mal deine runden
hier ich habe h so einen kleinen Parcour
aufgebaut wenn ich da jetzt ein Enderman
hinstelle einfach mal so jetzt sitzt er
in dem Teil drin und fährt da schön
seine Runden und zwar kann sich dieser
Enderman nun nicht teleportieren also
ich mache jetzt mal beispielsweise
toggle downfall so jetzt fängt das
ganzeä mich an zu regnen und ihr wisst
der Enderman bekommt
Schaden immer wenn es regnet
beispielsweise ihr kennt es glaube ich
denken sich Enderman nee ich will nicht
mehr leben ich teleportiere mich die
ganze Zeit hin und her er hat's versucht
und er ist auch manchmal so auf die
Kamera zugekommen ganz kurz ich weiß
nicht ob man das bei Youtube sieht weil
nur 30 fps sind und ich das hier gerade
irgendwie mit 60 Spiele jedenfalls
können sich er nicht
wenn es regnet und sie in einem min
sitzen und das war fact Nummer 1 fact
Nummer 2 kommt von Alex und zwar meint
Alex hey concrafter ich habe gerade eben
einen kleinen Fakt rausgefunden ist war
nicht sehr spektakulär aber den kennen
bestimmt noch nicht viele also wenn man
in der Minecraft 1.8 im Kreativmodus
einen Banner mit der mittleren Maustaste
nimmt bekommt man immer einen schwarzen
Banner ich habe hier einfach mal meine
vier lieblingsbanner hingehangen hier
ist nämlich einmal der graue finde ich
richtig cool den Grünen finde ich auch
schön diesen sanfarbenen hellblauen und
den orangenen und immer wenn ich jetzt
hier mittlere Maustaste drauf drücke
schwarzer Banner mittlere Maustaste
schwarzer Banner und schwarzer Banner
ich bekomme immer einen schwarzen Banner
ich weiß nicht woran es liegt eventuell
weil man nicht mehrere bekommen soll
oder weil man dann noch mal färben muss
oder so ich weiß es nicht ich verstehe
es nicht weil es ja sonst eigentlich
auch so ist wenn man irgendwie grüne
wolle irgendwie mit mit mittlerer
maustasse nimmt bekommt man ja auch
nicht eine weiße Wolle auf einmal
sondern dann bekommt man ja auch die
grüne wolle übrigens habe ich ein sehr
cooles seed erwischt ne ich bin hier
einfach SP hier ist so ein survival
Island und da hinten ist direkt so ein
unterwassertempel also ich weiß nicht
ich finde immer richtig coole seeds
wollt ihr übrigens mal Top 5 seeds als
nächstes ich mache so eine Top 5 Rei an
alle die das nicht kennen und Top 5
seeds wä eventuell bestimmt ganz cool
schreibt einfach mal in die Kommentare
oder zeig's mir mit einer Bewertung aber
das war auf jeden Fall Sache Nummer zi
danke an dich Alex der dritte fact wurde
mir zugesandt oder zugesendet ich weiß
immer noch nicht wie es heißt ich glaube
es heißt zugesandt aber ich habe mich
einfach an dieses zugesendet zu sehr
gewöhnt und dann diese Brille werde ich
mich einfach nie gewöhnen die ich jetzt
brauche wenn ich aufnehme aber gut es
kommt nämlich von Robert und zwar meint
Robert hi lu wenn du slashgif@p
farmerland eingibst bekommst du einen
Ackerboden das geht auch mit
slashgf@p@lit furnace da bekommst du
einen brennenden Ofen ihr seht hier
schon ich habe hier ein Ackerboden und
einen brennenden furnace einen
brennenden furnace allerdings dieser
brennende furnness der macht nichts der
brennt doch eigentlich nicht und wenn
ich hier irgendwie jetzt beispielsweise
dann mal so roh Schweinefleisch
reinpacke dann wird das auch nicht
gebraten das ist einfach nur diese
Textur ihr seht doch hier kommen keine
Partikel oder so das ist wirklich
einfach nur die Textur und zwar gibt
einmal diesen
command/give@pler also @p Farmland dann
bekommt man dieses diesen Ackerboden der
schon geackert ist und wenn man das hier
einingibt ld furnness also Lid steht für
light also schon angezündeter furnace
quasi bekommt man auch diesen komischen
Block und das ist dann schon
angezündeter Ofen das ist auf jeden Fall
ganz interessant dass man über diese
commands mittlerweile nahezu alles
bestimmen kann in Minecraft und ich
würde sagen das war fact Nummer 3 und
jetzt kommt fact Nummer 4 ich weiß
Freunde eigentlich ist heute Dienstag
und eigentlich kommt heute ein
geheimnisvolles Geräusch allerdings
steht dieses geheimnisvoll Geräusch seit
Wochen oder sogar Monaten so in der
Diskussion dass ich mir gedacht habe ich
lasse das jetzt erstmal weg und wenn es
von vielen vermisst wird mache ich es
eventuell wieder allerdings sonst halt
einfach nicht mehr weil halt viele mal
meinten oh das regt voll auf das sind
Minecraft facts und nicht ganz vololl
Geräusche und alles mögliche und
deswegen ich hatte jetzt einfach mal
gedacht dass ich das jetzt einfach mal
weglasse allerdings habe ich in der
letzten Folge mal gefragt was denkt ihr
eigentlich was diese zwei in diesem
Sandsteinblock zu suchen hat und die
beste Theorie kommt von dou l und er
meint sandsteintheorie du hast fünf
facts gezeigt der fünfte war der mit dem
Sandstein davor gab es vier facts nun
rechnen wir die Zahl vier plus die Zahl
auf dem Block also plus die zwei somit
erhalten wir sechs in Minecraft gibt es
zwei verschiedene Arten von Spinnen also
6 durch 2 nun erhalten wir drei was
liegt der drei am nächsten genau das
Dreieck und was Verb man mit dem Dreieck
richtig die Illuminaten so einen
Schwachsinn habe ich echt noch nie
gehört habe ich ab gesagt das dümmste
dieser am weitesten hergeholteste
Kommentar nehme ich einfach mit rein ins
Video und ich fand es einfach richtig
behindert was er da geschrieben hat
deswegen double l echt kriegst du ein
Applaus von mir so einen Schwachsinn
einfach aber gut vor allem weil ich an
dem Tag einfach auch noch Illuminaten
Dokus geguckt habe und mich da so total
für interessiert habe wo diese Folge
noch drausk wegen Sandstein und Gravur
und und was weiß ich aber jetzt geht's
weiter mit den fact der vierte fact
wurde mir zugesandt von Johannes und
zwar mein Johannes es ist zwar nicht
ingame aber trotzdem mit Minecraft zu
tun und interessant wenn man im Launcher
vor dem Hauptmenü mal runtersoll zu den
Erneuerung von der Version 1.7.2 steht
als Letzter pun removed Herobrine das
ist eine Sache die hat wahrscheinlich
jeder schon irgendwie mal mitbekommen
allerdings habe ich trotzdem 150 Mails
in meinem Posteingang wenn ich einfach
mal suche removed Herobrine die einfach
mir das sagen dass es unten drunter bei
jeder Version steht dass Herobrine
entfernen wurde und das ist wirklich
beiahe zu jeder Version und zwar kam ja
damals diese Gerüchte auf oh es gibt
Herobrine und so und so ein prozentige
Chance dass Herobrine auftaucht und man
weiß nicht ob es nur Gerüchte sind oder
ob es ih wirklich gibt allerdings hat
sich moang dann immer diesen Scherz
erlaubt und bei jedem Update einfach
hinten unten drunter geschrieben removed
hero so ja jetzt wurde herobr wirklich
rausgenommen und dann beim nächsten
Update 1.9 wir wieder unten runter
stehen ja jetzt haben wir herobr
wirklich mal rausgenommen also es ist so
ein kleiner SH sichmer erlaubt und ich
rede wieder viel zu schnell aber einfach
nur Freunde das bitte nicht mehr als F
zu senden das habe ich jetzt 150 mal
mein Posteingang aber gut das war fact
Nummer 4 und eventuell wussten es ja
manche noch nicht also ich weiß ja
nichtcrafter ein sehr sehr beunruhender
F das handelt sich um die Schallplatte
11 die den Herobrine schplatte ist und
zwar sind alle Sounds von Minecraft
imordner bei Proz in einem ogg Format
kennst du das ja aus den
audiosparbeitung also wenn du diese
musikcd ogg in eine WAV format audiorat
umwandel konvertierst und dann diese mit
einem Spek Programm abspielen lässt
Programm verlinkt dann bemerkst du dass
am Ende ein gut erkennbarer Skin oder
die anderen herobr Skin erscheint kurios
am Ende ganz am Ende kommen schwer
erkennbare zifferern zum Vorschein
Achtung der Ersteller dieser Musik ist
ja c418 jetzt kommt C ist hexadezimal
für 12 und im spekogram erscheint 12 418
also aus dem C wurde eine 12 bleib wie
Du Bistis ja danke an dich Ender crisis
LP für diesen fact ohne dich wä ich auf
dieses easterck quasi nie aufmerksam
geworden weil es ist quasi ein eastereg
und zwar ist diese Schallplatte einfach
ich blende euch davon jetzt einfach mal
ein Foto ein seht ihr schon wenn man das
ganze die Schallplatte diese ogg Dateien
ein wv umkonvertiert und dann mit diesem
Programm noch und dann mit diesem
Spektrogramm Dingsbums dann kommt Hal
dieser Audiospur bei raus und da erkennt
man dann halt dass da dieser Herobrine
Skin mehr oder weniger auftaucht das
finde ich schon extrem beunruhigen bzw
als ich das gelesen habe dieses Bild
gesehen habe in hochauflösen dachte ich
mir so da kommt einfach mal das macht
dann irgendwer stellt euch mal vor
irgendwer nimmt einfach so eine
Audiodatei her und macht das ein
spektogramm und sieht auf einmal so ein
her Gesicht da wird man sich do auch
denken h wo bin ich denn jetzt gelandet
also das ist schon irgendwie so ein
bisschen komisch bisschen krank ist auf
jeden Fall ein wirklich schöner fact
muss ich echt sagen dan kann dich Ender
crisis LP und das war fact Nummer 5 wenn
es euch gefallen hat heute würde ich
mich wirklich sehr sehr über eine
Bewertung freuen auch wenn ihr eventuell
Top 5 seeds haben wollt und FS weiterhin
an craft@gmail.com schreiben und dann
sehen wir uns in einer nächsten Folge
wieder tschüss